- What drew you to music?
Why did you have such a passion for it?
- It was just innate it was divine
I don't know.
I started out on the side of music
maybe that had something to do with it.
I was obsessed with the sound of music
word for word, I could recite everything.
But I was, when I was young,
I couldn't get to the end.
Every time it turned that corner,
with the fighting and all that stuff
where it kind of tune out,
but everything up to
that I was obsessed with.
I was obsessed with Michael Jackson.
I used to go out on my balcony in Nigeria,
we have this balcony with no railings
and it was right in front of a main street
in front of bar beach,
(speaking foreign language)
and I'd stand there...
- Can we just talk about it first.
- (laughs)
- That you have a
balcony with no railings?
- Yeah.
- So, like it's just...
- It's just like that.
- Platform, it's just a platform
- Yeah its just a platform
- You could totally die and fall off of.
- Yeah.
- Okay, cool keep going.
- And I would get on there
and I would do all the dances
I'd do every Michael Jackson dance.
- And you'd dance on this
platform without railings?
- Yeah and people would
drive around watching me
and I'd probably look kind of crazy.
- No, they probably thought
you're about to die.
they probably were like(both laughing)
"she's not gonna make it
she's gonna fall off."
- It wasn't too high though.
It was about one storey up.
- I love it though.
So you love dancing too.
I love music.
I love that I totally
- I'm with you obviously you love music
- I owned this the other day,
I complete this is surreal thing,
I put my kids to bed, I
have two small children,
I go in my room
and I blare like Florence and The Machine
or whatever I wanna listen to right then
and I dance around my room like by myself.
- Me too
- Just just living my best life.
- Yeah, and I look like a fool
but you know what?
- But it feels good
- There would be railing if
I was on the outside(laughs)
- But it feels good right?
I do it all the time
- It feels so good
- Yeah I turn off the lights.
- This has been a hard year.
- Yeah.
- Yeah. I got to dance it out
- No clubbing
- Yeah
- I know you can't do that.
I know what do you think
about maybe jamming
with my band like to commercial?
(crowd cheering)
Come on they're wanting you to.
Come on!
- Let's do it!
- Let's do it.
Hop on over there.
I love it.
I really want your outfit.
I wish I could fit into it and steal it.
I love first of all that guitar as well.
Okay, you're a rock star.
You look badass(chuckles)
- I've been trying to be my whole life.
I've been trying to be
flat slash my whole life.
- Here we go slash be slash(clapping).
Let's do it
(soft rock playing)